Queen Elizabeth says Princess Charlotte  bosses around her big brother Prince  George  [Music]  who's the boss Princess Charlotte on  Sunday the princess's great-grandma  revealed that the two-year-olds rules  over her four-year-old big bro  while speaking to a 10 year old girl  named Emily clay who won a Bible signed  by the Queen for a school religious  education project the exchange happened  at the Queen's estate in Norfolk and  according to the eastern Daily Press  when the Queen asked the young girl if  she looked after her six-year-old sister  Hadley Emily's mom chimed in saying  quote it's the other way around that's  when the 91 year old replied quote it's  like that with Charlotte and George how  cute is that but it won't be long until  the adorable tot is a big sister for  royal parents Prince William and Kate  Middleton are expecting baby number  three in April  [Music]  Oh